wer könnte denn Nachfolger des Kaisers
werden der am
24.06.2023 seine Kleider verloren das
ist wahrscheinlich die wichtigste und
gleichzeitig die am schwierigsten zu
beantwortende Frage in gestrigen Video
dem ersten Teil dieses Zweiteilers über
die Nachfolge gut jetzt haben wir euch
genau dargelegt wie es dazu kommen
konnte dass ich diese bedeutende
historische Entwicklung gerade jetzt
abzeichnet und wir haben euch
versprochen konkrete Namen zu nennen nun
natürlich stehen wir zu unserem Wort und
liegen im heutigen Video alle Karten auf
den Tisch falls ihr den ersten Teil noch
nicht gesehen haben sollte dann holt das
jetzt bitte über den Link oben rechts
hinter die Symbol oder unten in der
Videobeschreibung nach denn nur dann
werdet ihr auch den gesamt Zusammenhang
verstehen lass uns zuvor aber noch einen
kurzen Wärme Hinweis unseres tollen
Sponsors surfshark einspielen damit wir
danach sofort loslegen können
ist ein wirklich empfehlenswertes und
sicheres VPN welches z.B keinerlei
Verbindung starten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein deutscher privat nicht vor
allem Gefahren schützen die im Netz
laufen man muss nach wie vor lassen und
wissen was man tut aber es stellt
hierfür ein Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren
Vorteilen da zum einen erschwert es in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
eure Aktion im letzten nachzufolgen und
abzuhören mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
Anonymität im Netz erhöhen z.B mit dem
integrierten clean wird das alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Popups blockt
weiterer Vorteil ist dass sie so tun
könnt als während ihr an einem anderen
Ort so könnt ihr z.B auf Webseite
zugreifen die dem Land die wir gerade
seid nicht verfügbar werden ob daheim
oder im Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt
Zensur und diablocking ein Schnäppchen
Netflix und anderes dringend Ihre
Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten von
Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches Internet
fernsehen Ausland gucken mit Surfer kein
Problem aber das ist noch lange nicht
alles denn mit nur einem Surfer könnte
wirklich alle eure Endgeräte im VPN
registrieren Handys Notebooks oder sogar
euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de benutzt bekommt
ihr von uns auch noch einen Rabatt in
Höhe von 83% und oben deine ersten drei
Monate gratis dazu den Link zu diesem
Angebot findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video also nicht viel los
besorgt hat damit gleichzeitig auch uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links den ich euch ebenfalls in
die Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind
euch für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hättet ihr uns euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu
liefern so und nun lasst uns wieder
schnell zur Liste der heißesten
Thronfolger kommen die Putin in seinem
Amt ablösen oder ersetzen könnten auf
geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
könnte einer davon sein denn letzten
Endes stehen die russischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen vor der Tür sie
soll im März 2024 abgehalten werden als
Putin nicht aufgrund des Krieges
verschieben lässt lasst uns also ein
kleines Spiel spielen
[Musik]
gehen wir davon aus dass das derzeitige
Regime um jeden Preis die Kontrolle
behalten will und dass die derzeitigen
Machtzirkel und Putin genau das wollen
ihre Macht erhalten nehmen wir weiter an
dass sie schließlich zu dem Schluss
kommen dass Putin bereits ausgebrannt
ist und dass er ein neues Gesicht
brauchen das scheint gar nicht so weit
hergeholt zu sein Angesicht so viele
politischer militärischer und
wirtschaftlicher Misserfolge könnte dies
eine ganz logische Schlussfolgerung sein
bisher schien Putin für sie der optimale
Mann an der Spitze zu sein niemand
anderer hätte ihre Macht besser auf
sichern können niemand anders Verstand
ist besser mit dem Feuer zu spielen aber
was wäre wenn sie aufgrund der sich
rapide ändern Umstände zu einem anderen
Urteil gelangen nämlich ändere den
Herrscher bevor andere das ganze Regime
ändern wollte natürlich ist das alles
reine Spekulation aber es ist eine
Spekulation die sehr nützlich für uns
sein kann unter erörtern welche Namen im
Spiel sein könnten das heißt wer die
Spieler mit den größten Chancen sind um
einen Wechsel in Kontinuität vollziehen
zu können so wie er sich einst von
Jelzin zu Putin abgespielt hat
[Musik]
wer könnte Putins Nachfolger werden
also da wäre zum Beispiel Nikolai
patrouzevt er seit seinerzeit als
kgw-agent ein Freund Putin selbst
derzeit ist erst Sekretär des
Sicherheitsrates der Russischen
Föderation sein größtes Handicap
erforderte sehr radikale Positionen zur
Fortführung des Krieges gegen die
Ukraine manche behaupten sogar dass er
eine der hauptbefürworter ist ein
anderer Name könnte der von mittrim sein
mit der Farbe bereits zwischen 2008 und
2012 Russland marionettenpräsident damit
Putin weiter regieren konnte ohne sich
auch formell über die von der Verfassung
gesetzten Limits hinwegsetzen zu müssen
er steht Putin sehr nahe und ist ein
ganzes Stück Jünger 57 Jahre im
Vergleich zu 70 Jahren derzeit ist der
stellvertretender Vorsitzender des
russischen Sicherheitsrats wenn wir
jetzt halt jedoch zwei Probleme
einerseits wurden seine Popularität und
sein Image stark beschädigt als er einen
großen Korruptionsfall verwickelt war
der Oppositionsführer Alexander
aufgedeckt hatte Russland mit Milliarden
schweren Immobilien Imperium in
Verbindung gebracht ja wir alle wissen
das Russland Optionen praktisch Synonyme
sind aber was wollt ihr von mir hören
wenn man mit ansehen muss wieder
ehemalige Premierminister und Präsident
als diebunfähig ist ein Low Profile zu
halten eine Menge palästung Geld hat und
ständig regierungshubschrauber für seine
privat Angelegenheiten benutzt wird das
kein gutes Bild auf ihn nicht einmal in
Russland auf der anderen Seite hat in
den letzten Jahren eine wahre 180 Grad
Wende in seinem Diskurs vollzogen
während er früher als gemäßigt und
westorientiert galt droht er heute
gebetsmühlenartig oder inflationär mit
dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen und der
Apokalypse falls den Wünschen Russlands
nicht entsprochen wurde mein Video ist
sozusagen die Fleisch gewordene Atom
Drogen geworden eine nuklearer running
Gang 27 Februar 2023 Russland sagt
Waffenlieferungen an kfrechten die
Bedrohung einer globalen Atomkatastrophe
23 März 2023 Media sagt dass die Gefahr
eines Atomkriegs wächst
damit drei ukrainische Atomkraftwerke
und Atomanlagen in Europa anzugreifen
mit Videos sagt das Russland Atomwaffen
einsetzen könnte um den Krieg innerhalb
weniger Tage zu beenden
mit dem Einsatz von Russlands Arsenal
unmenschlicher Waffen und warnt dass der
dritte Weltkriege näher rückt und so
weiter und so fort
jap hat als letztes Jahr von Putin den
Job als Atom erpresbär bekommen mit Geld
heißt auf russischen nämlich Bär in
diesem Fall ein Bär der nur noch ein
einziges Kunststück drauf hat und es ist
wohl auch nicht gerade der postete Trick
der ist im gremmischen Affenzirkus zu
verteilen gab erscheint also nicht der
beste Ersatz zu sein zumindest nicht für
die Wiederherstellung der Beziehungen
zum Westen und damit für die Rückkehr
zum Verkauf von Gas und Öl an Europa
eine wichtige Voraussetzung dafür dass
Russland nicht pleite geht und die
großen Oligarchen irgendwann wieder auf
aller Welt mit ihrem Reichtum herum
kotzen können
in institutioneller Hinsicht ist der
derzeitige Premierminister Michael
meschustin der Nächste in der Reihe er
kommt allerdings aus der föderalen
Steuerverwaltung mit anderen Worten
Putin hat ihn genau deshalb in diese
Position gebracht damit er die Regierung
auf eine etwas technokratischereise
führt unterm Strich hat er nicht viel
politisches Kapital zu besitzen er
scheidet also vorerst aus tja und dann
gibt es einen Namen der ein richtiger
Joker sein könnte und trotzdem eine
gewisse Kontinuität bietet die Rede ist
von Sergej kirianco der 1998 mit 35
Jahren Jesus Premierminister war derzeit
ist der stellvertretende Leiter der
Präsident Verwaltung und zuvor leitet er
viele Jahre lange raus Atom das
staatliche kernenergieunternehmen über
das wir hier auf visualpolitik bereits
in einem eigenen Video berichtet haben
vor allem während seinerzeit bei Ross
Atom brauchte er sich ein dichtes
netzwerkkompetenter wie teuer
Führungskader auf dass ihm eine starke
Haus macht bietet
[Musik]
als der vororientiert verfügt über gute
Kontakte in den Westen und scheint auch
die Sympathie hochreiniger russischer
Geheimdienstler zu haben er würde auch
über gute Kontakte so vielen der
mächtigen Silo Wiki verfügen über die
wir schon oft gesprochen haben dabei
handelt es sich um Wesentlichen um
Politiker und hohe Beamte die gerade aus
der Sicherheitsdiensten kommen und heute
einen Ring der Macht um Putin bilden
mit anderen Worten wenn die derzeitigen
machtzwerke die Kontrolle über Russland
behalten und gleichzeitig einen Wandel
herbeiführen wollten der das Land
modernisiert und die Beziehung zum Rest
der Welt verbessert könnte dies ihr Mann
sein der Vizekönig dieser
dekirienkoputins Vordenker im Don Bass
wurde und wie er Russlands nach Kriegs
Image gestalten will Putins erster
stellvertretender Stabschef wurde zum
neuen Verbindungsmann des Kremls in den
selbst ernannten Volksrepubliken im Don
Bass und anderen von Russland besetzten
Gebieten in der Ukraine Berufen ihre
groß Untergebene wurden damit beauftragt
ein Nachkriegs Image für Russland zu
entwickeln eine Idee dabei ist Russland
als Kontinent der Freiheit für
rechtskonservative zu präsentieren einen
Kontinent der den Geist des alten
Europas bewahrt zufälligerweise wäre
jenkohl nicht abgeneigt diesen Kontinent
selbst anzuführen nachdem der kriter
zuvor bin ich Interesse an öffentlichen
Veranstaltungen gezeigt hatte ist in den
letzten Monaten immer häufiger in der
Öffentlichkeit aufgetreten einer
regierungshaltwelle merkte anders
wichtigste Trumpf sein gut etabliertes
Netzwerk von Mitarbeitern für uns eine
Fähigkeit ist schnell sein eigenes
Management-Team zu bilden und vergesst
bitte nicht als Putin an die Macht kam
war auch eher nicht nur relativ
unbekannt er trat auch mit dem gleichen
Auftrag an den festgefahrenen Krieg in
Tschetschenien zu lösen und das Land in
den Neuzeit und Globalisierung
durchführen auch er brachte damals aus
St Petersburg und im FSB ein
eingespieltes gefestigtes und
verschworenes und gut vernetztes
Management Team mit und hatte schon ein
paar Jahre
Verwaltung gediento wäre somit heute
quasi das Ebenbild Putins im Jahr 2000
er bringt den gleichen Stallgeruch mit
das heißt er könnte Putins klicke
Sicherheit garantieren und sich zur
gleichen Zeit nach außen als
einigermaßen unbefleckt und unverbrauch
darstellen als jemand der im Sinne
Russland handelt aber durchaus mit dem
besten verhandeln kann okay damit hätten
wir also die vier der herausragendsten
Namen die man in Betracht ziehen muss
oder zumindest drei von ihnen aber wie
ich euch bereits gesagt habe könnte es
auch sein dass Putin stürzt durch ein
plötzliches Ereignis ausgelöst wird und
dadurch dass ich ein neuer machte
durchsetzt in diesem Fall würde ist der
Top-Kandidaten natürlich ganz anders
aussehen der scheugruber Robby auf
sobianenturm hat einige seiner
Positionen verloren und ein Teil seines
Einflusses und seiner Ressourcen fließt
an eine Gruppe von Oligarchen aus der
orzero-kooperative rotenbergs
cobaltschuks und Co diese Gruppe die ein
großes Interesse daran hat den Krieg
unter allen Umständen zu beenden wird
uns auf keinen Fall gewinnen lassen sie
wird den Präsidenten dazu bringen die
Niederlage zu akzeptieren und die
oberste macht an einen von dieser Gruppe
ernannten Nachfolger kirienko grigorin
zu übergeben aber wartet einen Moment
wir sind bei dieser ganzen Geschichte
eventuell etwas zu voreilig es gibt
nämlich eine hochkritische Frage die wir
noch beantworten müssen könnte es Putin
gelingen seine Macht wieder zu festigen
in gewisser Weise wäre das eine weitere
Alternative zur aktuellen Situation
Putin könnte den Stier bei den Hörnern
packen und versuchen seine Macht zu
konsolidieren und wieder der Putin zu
werden den wir uns alle auf den Rücken
des Bären vorstellen doch dafür
bräuchtet der russische Staatschef zwei
Dinge erstens muss er den Krieg in der
Ukraine beenden ohne eine Niederlage zu
erleiden und zweitens muss eine große
politische Säuberungsaktionen bester
stalinistischer Manier durchführen und
warum nur weil Säuberungen nicht nur
dazu dienen Unruhestifter und die
Dissidenten muss zu werden sondern auch
um die eiserne Faust zu zeigen und jetzt
haltet euch fest dabei müssen wir gar
nicht so weit bis zum schlechter Stalin
zurückgehen das mit den Säuberungen hat
nämlich auch schon Putins Vorgänger
Bares jetzt 1993 getan als das Land am
Rande eines Bürgerkriegs stand
im September 1993 hingel ziehen in den
Seilen seine Regierung war ein Desaster
oder erreichte keines ihrer großen Ziele
um diese Dynamik zu ändern ordnete er
die Auflösung des kongressesportierten
Russlands und des obersten an weil diese
seine Wirtschaftsreformen Behinderten
der Kongress lebte dass die Kredit des
Präsidenten jedoch ab und stimmte
stattdessen für ein
amtsenhebungsverfahren die Abgeordneten
verbarrikadierten sich in der Duma und
jetzigen reagierte mit seiner besten
verhandlungswaffe die Duma wurde durch
Panzer beschossen und die Abgeordneten
wurden mit militärischer Gewalt
vertrieben am Ende setzte yelizien
seinen Willen durch
klar die aktuelle Situation
unterscheidet sich von der 1993 in
vielen Punkten aber in gewisser Weise
können wir einen gemeinsames sich
wiederholendes Muster erkennen falls er
weiterhin an der Spitze Russlands
bleiben will muss Putin ein Machtwort
sprechen und jede abweichende Meinung
ausmerzen und seine Macht auf sehr
sichtbare Weise wiederherstellen die
Frage ist wird er dazu in der Lage sein
[Musik]
nun die jüngsten Ereignisse deuten
darauf hin dass seine Position dafür
nicht mehr stark genug ist die Tatsache
dass er nicht in der Lage war die Wagner
Mutter hat zu bestrafen und sie sogar
hoheitlich bei sich empfing ist ein
starker Beweis dafür und ja genau dieses
Bild ist in Russland selbst aktuell weit
verbreitet auch wenn sich die Kreml
Propaganda wie im Walde treffen ganz
kräftig dagegen stellen
26 Juni 2023 heute habe ich pregorians
Erklärung gehört sie ist in wesentlichen
ein Aufruf zur weiteren Rebellion und in
versucht sich als ruhiger weißer Mann zu
präsentieren ich bin schockiert und
empört dass der Verräter unter der
Bellen noch auf einem Fuß ist und seine
staatsfeindlichen Aktivitäten fortsetzen
kann er arbeitet weiterhin für unsere
Feinde und für die Niederlage Russland
im Krieg Viktor im mannovic Alex
ehemaliges Mitglied des obersten sowie
der UdSSR und ehemalige Abgeordneter
staatsnummer der Russischen Föderation
zu allem Überfluss bedeutet alles darauf
hin dass der Krieg in der Ukraine Putins
Position mit immer mehr
Opfer neue Niederlagen und eine arme
medienpräsidenten und seine größ
wahnsinnigen Ideen zunehmen satt hat
weiter beschädigen wird siehe das Fiasko
mit General major Poppe auf dass wir
eingangs erwähnt haben popovs aus und
Entlassung stellt ein deutliches Symptom
dessen da wie und wohin der Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine verläuft der
verärgerte general beklagte sich wie
schon zuvor wagner-chef bregoschin über
die zunehmenden russischen Verluste
angesichts der anhaltenden ukrainischen
Russland nichts entgegenzusetzen habe
die russische Streitkräfte würden
schlicht und einfach nicht mehr über
ausreichende Fähigkeiten verfügen um auf
die ukrainische Artillerie zu reagieren
sei es durch Aufklärung oder
Gegenangriffe ich habe die Dinge beim
Namen genannt und mich auf das
wichtigste konzentriert die Tragödie des
modernen Kriegs diese ist das Fehlen von
gegen Batterie Kampf Aufklärung und die
massiven Verletzungen unserer Brüder
durch feindliche Artillerie generalmaier
Ivan Popov bemerkenswerterweise denken
sich Papa auf jüngste Aussagen mit den
Front berichten unabhängiger
Berichterstatter und auch mit unseren
Analysen aus dem vorletzten Video seit
dem Beginn Offensive hat die Ukraine
zwar mehr schwere Panzer verloren als
Russland aber das war durchaus
eingeplant denn mittlerweile verfügt
Kiew sowieso über mehr einsatzbereite
Panzer als Moskau die Ukraine hat jetzt
mehr Panzer als Russland nach dem Putin
über die Hälfte seines Panzer Arsenals
verloren hat neuen Daten zufolge verfügt
die Ukraine nun über mehr Panzer in
ihrem Arsenal als Russland während sie
ihren Rückstand bei Haubitzen und
mehrfach Raketenwerfern verringern
konnte die Lieferungen Hunderter
schwerer Waffen durch die westlichen
Verbündeten in den letzten Monaten haben
das Kräfteverhältnis dramatisch
verändert wenn die Ukraine hatte mehr
Waffen erhalten als Russland verloren
hat der russische panzerbestand hat sich
seit Beginn der Invasion praktisch
halbiert von 3400 auf etwa 1.400
inzwischen hat die Ukraine in diesem
Jahr 471 neue Panzer von ihren
Verbündeten erhalten weitere 286
befinden sich auf dem Weg so dass das
vor kriegstarsenal von 1987 Panzern auf
über 1500 aufgestockt wurde am 4 juli
sagte der britische Verteidigung Chef
Android Ken das Russland fast die Hälfte
seiner Kampffähigkeiten in der Ukraine
verloren habe und dass eine Industrie
große Schwierigkeiten hätte die Verluste
auszugleichen reddigin vor dem
Verteidigungsausschuss des Parlaments
letztes Jahr hat sie 10 Millionen
Artillerie Granaten verschossen kann
aber bestenfalls eine Million Granaten
pro Jahr produzieren sie hat 2500 Panzer
verloren und kann bestenfalls 200 Panzer
pro Jahr produzieren das heißt die
Ukraine kann es sich durchaus leisten
Panzer zu verlieren wenn sie dafür noch
mehr russische Artillerie vernichtet
genau das ist ihr aktueller
zermürbungsfokus der dann zur nächsten
Phase der gegen Offensive führen kann
und dieses Artillerie Duell verläuft wie
Pop Off nun bestätigt hat äußerst
unzufriedenstellend für Russland während
dagegen auch wenn sie dem südenscheid
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte bei den
Artillerie Verlusten mit 1 zu 4 die
Oberhand zu behalten mit anderen Worten
für jede Haut bitte die die Ukraine
verliert verliert Russland 4 tja so
sieht erfolgreiche Zermürbung aus
und sie ist kein Zufall der ukrainische
Vorteil ist das Ergebnis ihrer modernen
Artillerie Geldschein die durch
Radaranlagen zur batterieabwehr und
aufklärungsdrohnen sowie bessere
feuerunterstützungssysteme getragen wird
diese stammen aus den
militärhilfepaketen der NATO-Staaten und
das bedeutet dass der Vorteil der
Ukraine mit der Zeit immer größer werden
wird die Zeit spielt nun mal gegen die
Außen denn diese können wie der
technisch noch produktionsmengenmässig
mit der geballten Industrie machte
NATO-Länder oder anderen Verbündeten der
Ukraine mithalten und das meine Lieben
Zuschauer könnten noch nicht mal China
aber das ist ein ganz anderes Thema für
ein ganz eigenes Video also vergesst
bitte nicht das Abo unbedingt mit
Glöckchen falls ihr es nicht verpassen
möchtet die nun von den USA versprochene
steuermunition für die ukrainische
Artillerie wird den Abstand zwischen den
Kommandanten noch vergrößern und die
russischen Artillerie Verbände weiter
ausbluten lassen Pop auf konnte dem wohl
einfach nicht mehr weiter zusehen sein
Schritt war die Fortsetzung jedes für
den Camel brandgefährlichen Trend den
Goschen begründet hatte der beste Beweis
dafür dass der Putsch noch lange nicht
vorbei ist er ist vielmehr in eine
latente schleichende Phase übergegangen
Pop Ausfall deutet auf die sich
vertiefenen bruchtlinien und wachsenden
Spannungen und nun auch innerhalb der
offiziellen russischen Streitkräfte hin
denn während der Wagner Aufstand zwar
Moskau nicht erreichte ist die Botschaft
die gegens immer noch lebendig diese
lautet die Invasion läuft nicht gut und
die Kommandeure sind zunehmend wütend
auf scheuko und gerissen auf die ihre
Posten nur dank ihrer Loyalität so
Wladimir Putin und nicht wegen ihrer
Kompetenz als gute Befehlshaber
kriegsein haben besonders
besorgniserregend für den krabbel
während Kreuz stehen könnte sich der
wachsende Unmut des russischen Militärs
auf Vladimir Putin richten vor allem
wenn die ukrainische gegen Offensive
bedeutende Gebietsgewinne er bringt wir
arbeiten momentan übrigens an einem
eigenen Video zur Eroberung der Krim
also wie gesagt abonniert uns falls euch
dieses Thema interessiert aber zurück
nach Moskau seit Jahrzehnten hat die
russische Elite die aus den Reihen des
sowjetischen Geheimdienstes stammt die
russischen oligarischen nach der ihrer
baresien die Schach gehalten doch
niemand weiß wie sich ein Showdown
zwischen den Silo Wiki und dem
russischen Militär vor dem Hintergrund
eine Niederlage im ehemaligen
sowjetischen Raum entwickeln könnte ein
solch düsteres Abdriften ins Chaos
könnte die Nation an den Rand eines
Bürgerkrieges vor der Haustür der NATO
bringen während einer russischer
Bürgerkrieg vor ein paar Jahren noch
fast unvorstellbar war hat die Wagner
Meuterei dazu geführt dass er nun in
aller Munde ist und die
zermürbungstraktiker Ukraine dezimiert
nicht nur das russische Waffenarsenal
sondern auch die Moral der Truppen und
ihrer Kommandeure die Nerven liegen
wahrlich blank insgesamt könnte ein
entscheidender ukrainische Durchbruch zu
einer groß angelegten militärmeuterei in
der Russischen Föderation führen so wie
dem von 1917 an dessen Anfang der
Zerfall des Zaren Reiches und letzten
Endes die Errichtung des so wird Union
stand auch ähnliche Weise wird ein
militäraufstand heute auf einen
Dominoeffekt Auslösen der möglicherweise
in den endgültigen Zusammenbruch der
Russischen Föderation münden könnte denn
wenn Putin bisher nicht in der Lage war
die volle Kraft seiner Macht gegen den
Aufstand der bahngruppe einz Essen ist
nun alles andere als klar ob er dazu in
Zukunft in der Lage sein wird und den
System ist eindeutig geschwächt es
stützte sich auf drei Pfeiler seine
persönliche Legitimität seine
weitreichenden finanziellen Mittel und
seine Fähigkeit mit ihrer Hilfe Probleme
zu lösen so wie seine angebliche
Kontrolle über den Sicherheitsapparat
und dieses System hat in allen Bereichen
Schaden erlitten wladimir Putin hat
seine Legitimität verloren erst erklärte
er Pre Goschen zum Verräter dann schloss
er einen Deal mit ihm Putins Job wäre es
eigentlich auch interne Streitigkeiten
Voraus zu ahnen oder zumindest zu
verhindern dass sie zu einer Gefahr
werden und in dieser Hinsicht hat er
versagt zweitens die russischen Reserven
scheint zwar noch solide zu sein aber
tatsächlich wurden sie vom Krieg
buchstäblich aufgezählt das heißt das
längst nicht mehr so viel Geld vorhanden
ist drittens der Sicherheitsapparat hat
sich als unzuverlässig erwiesen und das
bedeutet insgesamt dass der Staat als
Ganzes schwächer geworden ist das
Bemerkenswerteste an dieser Meuterei war
meiner Ansicht nach dass sie in gewisser
Weise sogar ein Vertrauensvotum für das
Putin Regime war und der Großteil der
Menschen dachte es sei besser erst
einmal abzuwarten wie sich das Ganze
entwickeln würde das Problem liegt darin
dass auch Putin nur ungern und zögerlich
schwierige Entscheidungen trefft
angesichts von Schwierigkeiten auf die
es keine einfache Antwort gibt zögert er
wartet ab und ist dabei wie gelähmt
marcelotti britischer Historiker als
ehemaliger Geheimdienstmann wird Putin
also er versuchen seine Macht im
Verborgenen und hinterrücks auszuspielen
aber hierzu müsste erstmal wieder die
angeschlagene Kompetenz seines
Geheimdienstes Baby wiederherstellen ein
Vorhaben dem Loyalität motivierte
Säuberungen nicht gerade zuträglich sind
er muss einen heilenden Balanceakt
vollführen indem er nicht zu viele
kompetente Leute absägt gleichzeitig
nicht zu viele potenzielle verräte in
Schlüsselpositionen beläst wenn er bei
dieser Grad Wanderung abrutscht könnte
das seinen Untergang beschleunigen oder
gar zum Abschluss führen und deswegen
werden wir in einer Reihe weitere Videos
all die zahlreichen Faktoren betrachten
die dabei eine wichtige Rolle spielen
die internen macht Kämpfe im kremli
zwischen Armee und Geheimdienst
dem Volk und nicht zuletzt die Rolle der
Ukraine und ihre Verbündeten vergesst
also wie gesagt bitte nicht das Abo
unbedingt mit Glöckchen um mit uns am
Ball zu bleiben und das vollständige
Bild zu verstehen und bis dahin würde
uns interessieren was ihr dazu meint
glaubt ihr das Putin einen Durchbruch
schaffen wird wie hält sie 1993 oder
ähnelt die Situation in Russland eher
der Sowjetunion von 1991 oder gar den
zahlreich von 1917 was glaubt ihr wie
nah ist Putins Ende welche anderen
Kandidaten außerdem von uns genannten
haltet ihr für wahrscheinlich wie immer
sind wir auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt
habt falls ja gebt uns bitte ein Like
teilt das Video mit euren Freunden und
diskutiert es mit ihnen natürlich wollen
wir uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch wenn das halt dieses Projekte
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]